a touch of the elbow is as close as
you'll get to the dawn of infectious
disease doctors at the moment
in a rare broadcast interview Peter Piot
who helped to discover the Ebola virus
said kovat 19 is far more of a threat oh
this is much much worse than Ebola Ebola
requires very close contact for
transmission people are very scared of
it but frankly it is usually very
contained I mean we have some exceptions
but it's because it's a respiratory
transmitted virus that makes it so
worrisome and it's very infectious
because there's so much virus in the
throat so this is literally something
you can catch by just talking to
somebody he said president Trump's
restriction on non-us citizens flying
from many European countries makes
little sense the virus is already
widespread and largely undetected in the
United States thank you once again
President Trump took everybody by
surprise by a decision which is frankly
pretty bizarre in the sense the US has
in country transmission as lots of cases
so I can only think that this is a
political decision and it's hard to
imagine that this would have any impact
on control of Kovan 19 there will be
many thousands of cases and more deaths
in the coming weeks but so far modern
medicine has little to help those most
vulnerable because there is no treatment
there is no vaccine we're relying on on
good hygiene is almost back to the dark
ages of medicine in many ways and it's
this basic principles here it's like
back to the times of the Spanish flu 100
years ago where that killed you know 50
million people however we have
antibiotics that can treat pneumonia
there are respirators we we are better
equipped and I'm quite optimistic that
okay let's say by April sometime in
April we will have effective therapy but
reasonable hope that we will know soon
vaccine that's going to take a much
longer time the big concern is Africa
Ebola had a catastrophic impact on
countries with under-resourced health
services deaths from coronavirus could
be even greater and once again the world
will be called upon
to help Thomas more Sky News